hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm gonna answer a question from
one of my newsletter readers Francis who
was in France so hi Francis from France
and is running a shiatsu clinic and is
having a hard time getting past the
survival stage so she's grown her
business as she can kind of barely
support herself but wanted to grow the
business to the next step and she sees
local businesses leaving flyers and
their people's windshields on their cars
and she doesn't want to do that kind of
stuff one is wondering how she could
grow her business so she's in the rural
city in France and wanted some advice so
Frances I think for you what I would do
if I was your business I would look at
who my target customer is and it sounds
like you're kind of targeting the people
who are in your local community and I
would look at two things one I look at
business I try to get in with the
business customers and have them buy it
on behalf of their employees so a big
trend right now with employers is
keeping their employees happy making
sure they're not stressed out and this
might be a good way for you to be able
to get in with them so you can have the
businesses by otsuma serve the services
on behalf of their clients and you can
have some kind of budget or you have the
shot suit day where people come in or
you go to their office the great thing
about going after business clients it's
a couple things first usually it's much
bigger ticket value so if you're going
after individual customers they often
are you know penny pinchers and they may
not have the money right now and they
only come when they really need it and
they may not come for you know a number
of months or you know only come one time
and this low dollar value every time
where businesses will often spend a lot
more especially you can find a way to
make it an ongoing thing with them where
if you're showing that their employees
are really happy with what's going on
then
want to keep doing this if you can
become an important part of their
business
then they're gonna always want to work
with you and you have ongoing repeat
business from clients who are paying a
lot more money so I look at trying to
get in with the businesses and be a part
of the program to help their employees
and companies can use it as a way to
thank their employees recognize their
top employees use it as a recruitment
tool for when somebody's trying to join
the company to say you know here's some
of the services that we provide for our
employees so look at the local
businesses and see if there's a way you
can integrate with them and be part of
their their health program and health
and wellness program to help with their
employees I'll be the first thing the
second thing you mentioned you're in
rural France and the area that you're in
is really picturesque and really
beautiful so I would try to see if
there's any market for tourists now to
know how many tourists are in your city
and how you know how many tours you get
every year but if you have any kind of
tourism industry I try to partner up
with whoever is bringing people into the
city and have your service is something
that people could buy as well that could
be a great thing for tourists to come in
and do and relax if you had especially
some kind of you know nice setting or
you can go on location to hotels for
example or Inns wherever people are it's
like to be part of a package at the
offer then this could be a great way to
be able to get people because people are
spending money on trips they want to
relax they want to feel healthy they may
have had a hard time traveling and
they're doing a lot of things when they
doing a vacation so this could be a
great way for them to relax and people
are a little looser with their money
when they're on vacation as opposed to
when they're you know just kind of live
in their day to day lives so I think for
you what I would do is just try to
change who my target market is go after
the business customers and try to
attract more tourists in terms of
specific things that you could do for
business instead you can go and
obviously start talking to entrepreneurs
business owners get in there introduce
yourself explain the benefits of working
with you
I'd also try to see if I can get a
column written so I look at my local
media whoever is the local paper and try
to have a regular ongoing column about
workplace workplace health wealth health
health and wellness and if you can
create content for them on a regular
basis part of it can relate to shiatsu
otherwise is just general health and
wellness and obviously you have a link
back to your website or where people can
contact you for more information and if
you're seen as the expert in wellness
for corporations and businesses then
when they have a need they're gonna call
you and there's an opportunity to be
able to sell them so I try to see if I
can get in the media somehow um you know
if you have radio station try to be an
expert try to host your own show
potentially or try to create a column
doesn't have to be big if you're selling
to your local area whatever local media
you have try to get in with them and if
you're selling the tourist I would try
to create online content so I don't know
if you have a website or not but I
definitely create a website and here I
would start talking about not only the
benefits of using shots ooh and how you
can help tourists who are coming but
also talk about your city and how
picturesque it is and take pictures
I mean partner up with the local Inns or
hotels to be able to offer some kind of
package deal and you know create that
kind of content because there are people
who are you know in North America and
elsewhere who want to come to real
friends and enjoy that experience and
have the you know the lifestyle that is
relaxing and they might want to buy a
shiatsu massage at the same time so why
do they pick one rural city over another
city you know it's what they research
and what people tell them about so you
could be part of that process and create
a site that has content that promotes
your city and how picturesque it is and
and take pictures and profile the local
businesses so you can show how great a
city it is and encourage tourists to
come and the people who do come are
gonna want to buy your shots or services
as well so hopefully that helps it may
be a couple new ideas that you haven't
thought of that was what I would do if I
was running your business if you guys
liked the video please give it a thumbs
up below and it also love to hear what
you have to think if you wanna leave a
comment under the video and stay tuned
for next episode
you